Nói ngày ngày 6 năm năm 2018, công an thình phố Hàn Nội cho biết đơn vị đã giá quyết định khởi tổ bị càng
và bắt tạm giám bàn tị tâm. Xin năm 2019, tình chú sả bác quan tình tuyên quan về tội,
giết người. Tâm là mẹ dự của bế gái bốn tuy bị bỏ hành giấn đến từ vong sế giang ngày
18 năm năm 2018, tại ngó bà mi mốt với khả trạc phương phu dính, Hàn Nội.
Chứ đó, các quan cạnh giá đều trạc công an thình phố đã giá quyết định khởi tổ hủ an, khởi tổ bị càng
bình bến miệp, sinh năm 2018, tình chú sả tình lâm tình như mình về tội dính người. Như tiền đã đưa,
miệp và bản thị tâm xí xong với nhau như vụ trồng và thư trọt tảy ngó bà mi mốt với khả trạc phương phu dính.
Trường ngày 18 năm 2018, hình bà tâm đi trời về thị thế trong hát trình bị lấy bán cạo ra.
Châu dòng chào an cũng như tâm đã lấy dế bệnh lên tiếp nhiều lần vào cùng đồng và mặt chào.
Đánh xong, tâm bắt trong hát đứng góc nhà thị thế trấu đi vệ sinh đi tâm dùng tây đánh vào mặt dồi bảo cháo và thăm.
Một lúc sau thay trong không gạo khóc sĩ dụng lưỡi thị thế dòng hoài,
sau đó, trọt hát được đưa đi cấp cứu ở bình vình a và từ vòng.
Qua sinh đấu tranh, hiệp và tâm còn khai yện tự sinh bảo hành, đánh đập trọt hát thậm chí bỏ đối dừng ngày.